اذا مشاهدينا مع دوران عجله الحرب يبدو ان
مصائب قوم عند قوم مزيد من الفوائد وهنا
نتحدث عن الضرر الذي لحق بصناعه الاسلحه
الروسيه والفائده التي جنتها دول اخرى اذا
الحرف في اوكرانيا قدمت جزءا من حصه روسيا
في سوق السلاح العالمي مع بحث عملاء
لموسكو عن مورد اخر للسلاح لطالما كانت
روسيا هي ثاني اكبر مصدر للاسلحه في
العالم بعد الولايات المتحده الا ان
نسبتها عالميا انخفضت من 22% الى 16 في
المئه كما نتابع فرنسا احدى الدول
المستفيده من مشاكل روسيا لترتفع الحصه
الفرنسيه من صادرات الاسلحه العالميه من
سبعه الى
11% صربيا حليفه روسيا اعلنت الشهر الماضي
اجراء محادثات مع شركه دسوق الفرنسيه
لشراء مقاتلات من ط الاطفال بسبب صعوبه
الحصول على قطع غيار الاصول الصربي الحالي
روسي الصنع ايضا الفلبين بدورها الغى طلبا
لشراء سته عشره مروحيه نقل روسيه من طراز
17 في الاشهر التي تلت بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا البديل بالنسبه للفلبين جاء من
الولايات المتحده بشراء اثنتين مروحيه من
طراز بلاك هوك فيتنام ايضا بدات تبتعد عن
الاسلحه الروسيه بعدما كانت معظم وارداتها
من السلاح تاتي من روسيا وباشرت منذ اعوام
قليله توقيع عقود لشراء بعض المعدات
الامريكيه بما في ذلك طائرات الاستطلاع من
دون طيار اذا التراجع في صادرات السلاح
الروسي لدول لم يمنع زيادته لدول اخرى
مثلا بحسب مسؤول عسكري روسيه يقول بان
ارتفع الاهتمام بالاسلحه الروسيه من دول
في افريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه الميزه التي
تحتفظ بها الاسلحه الروسيه عن نظيرتها
الغربيه السعر مثلا دبابه ليوبارد اثنان
الالمانيه يقترب سعرها من 11 مليون دولار
بينما يقول سعر دبابه تي 90 روسيه عن نصف
هذا السعر